I grew up in the West, now I live in the East.
I love both, and in my work, I always try to merge both.
That's what I do and what I breathe and what I love.
I try to get inspirations from different dimensions.
I always walk around with my camera and I just love capturing moments.
I love discovering stories, telling stories and I translate that into products.
Being a creative, you really need to be open-minded.
You need to be able to discover new things.
There is no more boundaries.
We can reach each other,...
...find artists that you can relate to.
I'm the proof of that.
I take details from the past and I merge them with the future...
...and I think that's strong and powerful.